[Music]
there's a sadness that lingers
throughout child of light it's
communicated in the neglected
environments overgrown with foliage in
the tired inhabitants wasting their days
I could feel in the whimsical language
whose rhythmic cadence underscores the
sense of bewilderment that's
ever-present and there's the music the
quiet piano score that hammers home the
desperation child of light owns its
sadness flipping its fairytale facade
into one of quiet contemplation and soon
you're as sad as a citizen struggling in
this world such sadness didn't push me
away from child of lights
well the early going was difficult as I
expected light heartedness that never
came but once I became accustomed to it
somber tone I embrace the melancholy
it's rare to find an adventure that
isn't fixated on empowerment where
there's a little more than a dim light
to reach out for and it's incredibly
effective if you allow it in your heart
[Music]
Aurora is a princess who spends her days
and nights by her father's side
one night she rested her head and never
awakened at least not in her home
kingdom her father was beside himself
his tears would not abate nobody do his
kingly duties meanwhile roar found
herself in another world one filled with
sleeping giants and talking mice lost
jesters and punished gnomes and she
finds companions who lean on her when
their troubles become overwhelming
Aurora soars with a firefly named
igniculus by her side yes the princess
is imbued with flight to aid her in her
attempt to escape and rarely must you
touch ground once you've tasted the
clouds there's a kinetic freedom that
momentarily lets you forget your
problems but that doesn't last long
thorns and gates and waterfalls keep you
trapped within a narrow path
tempering any enthusiasm such
restrictions fit within the themes of
child Oh light though I longed for the
simple running and jumping from the
opening moments exploring the world on
foot had a tactile feel that drew me
into this environment more effectively
than the ethereal detached flying fly
you must those who stretch your wings
when you can because they're monsters
about to take issue with your presence
fights can be avoided if you wish for
aura has a sword and a heart that longs
for something better
so she faces her enemies with a steely
gaze although you take turns attacking
defending or healing during these
showdowns managing time is just as
important as swinging a sword you and
your enemies are in a race to see who
can cast an attack first and you can
manipulate events in your favor with a
Nicholas he can slow down foes or heal
you so there's an intense rhythm as you
vital launched an offensive before you
face retaliation
[Music]
the combat is enchanting as the
painterly artistic style and the one
piece where sadness doesn't dwell it's
here the roar and her companions forget
their larger problems to focus on the
threat before them maximizing your speed
is a constant challenge in which a
moment of locks niskanen race your hard
efforts attack with the right elements
cast haste when you're falling behind
and interrupt their advances to keep
your enemies frustrated such duels tax
your abilities demanding quick reactions
and even quicker decision-making
I often fell over matched in the tougher
fights sure I wouldn't be able to
overcome the deviousness before me by
never faltered child of life does an
amazing job of challenging without
becoming overbearing and that goes
through in the story
Aurora 2 is at our wits end but never
succumbs to her own doubts child of
light is a remark Allah venture in part
because of how different is the enticing
combat is easy to praise because of how
immediate and satisfying it is but I
could say the same thing about too many
games to count what drew me in to child
of light is how confident it is in its
own sadness it shows how engaging games
can be that aren't entirely fun that
make me feel an emotion that's all too
rare it's a game that makes me want to
hug a loved one or just sit quietly
though I think about what transpired
child light is a sad somber adventure
and I couldn't be happier about that
[Music]
you